fake x4 scenes a Chris Evans cameo
underwater scenes with Vanessa and
not-safe-for-work disney jokes were all
cut from Deadpool - yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
explaining everything we never got to
see in the Deadpool sequel Plus details
on an extended cut of the movie if this
is your first time here be sure to
subscribe to get all my Deadpool and
Marvel videos and leave a comment for a
chance to win some cool Deadpool - merch
spoilers ahead of course for the movie
so take care if you've not seen it yet
it was fun meeting the new x-force team
in Deadpool - even though our time with
them was pretty short but if you'd
watched the movies trailers you probably
thought we were going to get more time
with the new team than we did including
action scenes with both bedlam and
shatter star and that's exactly what the
filmmakers wanted you to think yes the
movies director and writers told Uproxx
that they filmed those extra scenes with
the actors in front of a green screen
knowing full well that they'd never put
them in the final film it was all done
with the aim of pranking the audience
and at one point they were even planning
to make individual character posters and
standees of the x-force members as well
however the studio told them to hit the
brakes in case audiences got too annoyed
when they saw the film the idea behind
the marketing of course was to make all
those sudden x-force deaths more of a
shock to viewers watching the movie in
the cinema which it certainly was there
was still a bit of a shame to see so
little of actors like Terry Crews Lewis
tan and Bill skarsgård there wasn't any
explanation in the movie about where
cable got his mutant powers or his metal
arm from however there is a potential
nod to his cybernetic arm and the
techno-organic virus from the comics in
a voiceover line in the trailer that we
never heard in the final film in the
film cable asks weasel whose most pain
you ever felt but this next line from
cable and the trailer was cut from the
movie maybe the kind that leaves you
man perhaps this audio is part of a
deleted scene where it could have been
an extended version of cables monologue
when he's interrogating weasel and based
on cables words it sounds like this
would have added yet another Star Wars
Easter Egg to the movie this time
referencing obi-wan Kenobi's words about
Darth Vader he's more machine than man
as for cables rich comic-book history
the movies writers told vulture that
they used the comics as guideposts while
adding their own spin on things
going more for the tone and feel of a
character than details and plot lines
and while the movie does feature some
nods to cables comic book backstory as
I've talked about in my Deadpool 2
Easter eggs video the screenwriters made
a conscious decision not to go heavily
into his background as they felt it was
too much information for a two-hour film
it's interesting that earlier versions
of the script did include cables
telekinetic powers though in the end
they didn't make it on screen
of course cable will be back in the
x-force movie and although they're not
writing it did pull two screenwriters
they will likely hear more in that film
about things like the techno-organic
virus that cable has in the comics also
according to plot leaks Deadpool -
originally included a scene of cable
breaking into a government facility to
steal the time travel device he uses to
go back to find the young fire fist of
course in the final film he already has
that device when we first see him in the
ruins of his former house as I mentioned
earlier it's becoming more normal for
major movies like Deadpool 2 and
Avengers infinity war to use fake scenes
or alternate takes in their marketing to
avoid spoilers in a comedy like Deadpool
tons of stuff was improvised in addition
to the script with Ryan Reynolds
delivering multiple riffs on scenes
which means there were just too many
jokes to fit in the film so director
david leitch deliberately included some
of those alternate versions in marketing
materials while others may appear on the
blu-ray and to give you a taste of what
that included here's a stack of
alternate and deleted lines and moments
from the Deadpool 2 trailers which ended
up different in the final film
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care additive beautiful
girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again louvered I pump the hate breaks
Thanos we're gonna form a super dupe and
grip absolutely right now let's go get
our ooh yeah your bullets they're really
fast 40 you times up you dumb that is
why Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants is
pure pornography oh god I wish I
finished college I think some of those
trailer lines were funnier than their
counterparts in the movie though others
in the film were funnier than in the
trailers especially as I wasn't
expecting them for example Pope the hate
breaks Fox and Friends it's a tricky
balance for studios as some fans might
appreciate the pleasant surprise of the
final movie ending up a bit different
while others might feel cheated of
moments they enjoyed in the trailers by
the way there was also a joke by Peter
teased in a TV spot that never made it
into the final Kurt I have both type 1 &
2 diabetes as it turns out we are
looking for someone with diabetes Peters
your man that line was likely ad-lib by
Rob Delaney who did a lot of
improvisation in his role as Peter by
the way
originally the filmmakers toyed with the
idea of one of the screenwriters playing
the part of Peter but Ryan Reynolds
recommend a catastrophe start Eleni
and while we did get some amusing shots
of Wayde scooting around the x-mansion
in Professor X's wheelchair this one of
him spinning around in front of a couple
of portraits of Abraham Lincoln and
Barack Obama didn't make it into the
movie there's an example of something
being digitally altered between the
trailer and the final film in the
propaganda posters behind five fists
which changed from the end is near in
the trailer to M days here in the movie
which is a very interesting x-men Easter
Egg you can learn more about in my
Easter Egg video the Deadpool sequel
certainly isn't short on post-credit
scenes as it is however they also filmed
an extra-credit scene featuring baby
Hitler which was initially going to
appear at the very end of the movie the
scene was set in a newborn nursery and
showed Deadpool deliberating over
whether to kill the baby lying in a crib
he eventually decided in favor saying
maximum effort as he went into
the infant the scene was deleted after
it left test audiences decidedly uneasy
so it seems that infanticide was a step
too far
even from the notoriously near the
knuckle comic-book character according
to the screenwriters there was also
another version drafted of that scene
which included Deadpool using a pen to
draw a mustache on the baby so he looked
more like adult Hitler before
dispatching him by the way it seems the
filmmakers couldn't entirely resist
including a baby hit the line in the
film deadpool asked cable why he didn't
just travel back to when fire fist was a
baby and kill him then or better yet
head back a little further and kill baby
Hitler while the baby Hitler end credits
scene was actually filmed another idea
the writers had for the post-credits
didn't make it past the writing stage
basically it was going to involve more
x-force interviews one of them with
actor Chris Evans reprising his role as
the Human Torch from Fox's original
fantastic four movies
sadly they never got as far as actually
asking Evans who's now best known as the
emcee used Captain America however the
reason they didn't end up with the Human
Torch post-credits is that Ryan Reynolds
came up with the idea for the green
lantern scene which closes the movie
with Deadpool traveling back in time to
shoot Reynolds who thinks he's made it
to the big time after he gets a script
for the much-maligned DC movie cesspool
- includes plenty of Easter eggs and
jokey references to movies owned by
Disney
however Ryan Reynolds has said that Fox
made him delete one particular Disney
related joke from the film cutting the
gag was a sore spot for Reynolds but
while he wouldn't reveal what the joke
was he did telling w that looking back
removing it was a wise decision of
course much of Fox has now been bought
by Disney whose CEO has previously said
there could be room for the r-rated Merc
on their future slate however the merger
deal isn't officially closed yet and it
seems it may have affected the virtually
fills a free Deadpool franchise which
normally takes aim at pretty much
everything given the humor in the
Deadpool movies you can imagine the kind
of innuendo the writers might have come
up with for a joke about Fox and the
mouse house getting together but as the
not-safe-for-work joke was a bit too
dark and at the expense of Disney we may
never find out exactly what we're
missing
an underwater scene with Deadpool and
Vanessa who's played by Morena Baccarin
was also chopped from the movie the
scene in question was a dream sequence
and filming for it involved an apartment
set being sunk 20 feet underwater and
Baccarin being strapped to a chair and
weights attached to her so she stayed in
place that Kareem was actually pretty
annoyed it ended up being Kurdish she
had to conference her massive fear of
being underwater both during the shoot
and during the scuba training to prepare
for it however as she told GMA unlike
Ryan Reynolds who seemed completely at
ease filming the scene she found it hard
to relax and thinks her anxiety may have
been picked up on camera which could be
why the scene was deleted it sounds like
this sequence was how the film was
originally going to depict Vanessa's
scenes with Deadpool in the afterlife
instead in the final film the afterlife
scenes look like they maybe take some
inspiration from the music video for our
heartache on me which also plays during
those scenes an alternate early version
of the script had Vanessa leaving wade
in him trying to get her back however
for the screenwriters Deadpool works
best when he's suffering and has nothing
so they killed off her character instead
in the comics vanessa is a mutant
shape-shifter known as copycats and as a
much more interesting role compared to
her part in both deadpool movie so far
and considering it's such a self-aware
comic-book movie the writers
storytelling choice makes Deadpool too
less adversive than it likes to think it
is over the years killing off female
characters merely to motivate male
characters and advance their comic-book
stories has been criticized with the
term women in refrigerators or fridging
being coined to describe this trope
because women have literally been
murdered and stuffed in a fridge to
quote Deadpool that's just lazy writing
and it's especially frustrating that
screenwriters decided not to develop
Vanessa's character a mutant house for
the sequel as after the first movie they
actually said they wanted to explore
that in future films it's also
interesting that after the writers
decided to kill Vanessa off their
original plan was for her to stay dead
and that's exactly what audiences saw
happened at the first screenings of the
film which didn't include any
time-traveling post-credit scenes as
they hadn't come up with the idea at
that point the end credits scenes were
actually filmed during additional
photography speaking of extra filming as
is the case with most major movies
Deadpool too
do some reshoots and in March this year
there were reports claiming the movie
was suffering from poor test screenings
after the rumors surfaced counter
reports appeared in the press possibly
leaked by the studio about three
separate sets of test screenings of
Deadpool - all of which scored very
highly exactly what went on there isn't
totally clear and the official line is
that reshoots were mostly to add more
scenes with the two characters cable and
Domino which test audiences really liked
but I wonder whether the eventual idea
to resurrect Vanessa also came about
because of reactions from those
screenings obviously test screenings are
confidential so there's no way of truly
knowing for sure whether claims about
good or bad tests can be fully trusted
at the end of Deadpool 2 there's a
credit that reads in memory of sook
Juana Harris in honor of the stunt woman
and pro racer who dies in a motorcycle
accident on the set of the movie in
Vancouver at the time of the tragic
event Harris was doubling for sassy
beats in what appears to have been an
action scene of Domino on a motorbike
and for obvious reasons the filmmakers
opted not to reshoot the scene for the
final film one new character we only saw
a little of in Deadpool 2 was black Tom
Cassidy originally he was going to have
a much bigger part in the movie acting
as a kind of devil figure whispering and
Russell's ear pushing him to criminality
comic-book fans will know black Tom as
an x-men villain and a mutant who can
use plant life to project and manipulate
energy there are some crazy comic book
storylines with the character and the
original idea for Deadpool - was for
black Tom to be the main villain of the
movie speaking to CBR the writers said
there was a scene planned where black
Tom would create hail storms of wood
from trees and also moved the entire
orphanage the idea was scrapped though
because the cost of those CG scenes was
too high for the budget and the
filmmakers decided to focus a CG money
instead on juggernaut so that's why
ultimately black Tom Cassidy's role was
cut back and the character was quickly
killed off the writers have said that
they regret this a little but added that
they can always use a time-travel device
to resurrect him if they want to there's
also a joke about a Deadpool 3 movie
which feels like it might have been
filmed specifically for the trailer but
it probably would also have worked as
one of the motormouth mercs many meta
moments within the movie it lives up to
the hype
plus-plus okay probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it if you're hoping all these
deleted scenes may mean there's a
possible extended cut in the works then
you're likely in luck as director david
leitch tell website Bloody Disgusting
that he hopes to share some lengthiest
scenes when the blu-ray release comes
out one particular extended scene that
leach teased happens in the opening
fight montage and is a single shot in
the bathhouse fight with the Yakuza
which he describes as a seamless 360
shot that's really fun some think the
screenwriters have said will be on the
DVD is a montage of Wade's various
attempts to kill himself after Vanessa's
death because if Deadpool's healing
factor each attempt fails of course but
in the extended scene we see Wade making
more and more violent attempt such as
jumping into a polar bear enclosure and
swallowing drain cleaner chemicals za z
beets also told Digital Spy about a very
funny back and forth scene between her
and Ryan Reynolds which everybody loved
but then parts of the script got
reworked and so it just didn't fit in
anymore so it looks like there's plenty
of scope for bonus domino and Deadpool
deleted scenes on the blu-ray now which
scenes do you wish had been included in
the movie and do you think it's a good
idea of filming fake trailer scenes for
big movies like Deadpool 2 and infinity
war be sure to comment and subscribe for
a chance to win this awesome Deadpool
merch and if you haven't seen my
Deadpool 2 Easter eggs video yet check
that out by tapping left or tap right
for my full deleted C's playlist for
marvel movies including infinity war
Black Panther and Thor Ragnarok thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers